pour en parler j'accueille le président
du groupe l'est républicain au sénat
bruno retailleau bonjour bonjour à vous
alors on l'a vu hier notamment dans la
manifestation hospitalière il ya
beaucoup de violence on l'a vu ces
derniers jours à dijon
comment vous expliquer ces violences
actuelles dans la société française
c'est l'échec c'est l'échec de la
politique des mails macron c'est l'échec
parce que on a organisé une forme
d'impunité quand on voit par exemple que
pendant le confinement et sous prétexte
du confinement
la ministre de la justice a libéré
quatorze mille détenus qu'elle a fait le
20 mai une circulaire pour décourager
l'emprisonnement en réalité madame
belloubet c'est la continuation de
madame taubira madame taubira en avait
rêvé madame des loubet le fait et on l'a
bien vu aussi l'acte fondateur
finalement du quinquennat de monsieur
macron c'était la décision sur notre
dame des landes où une hyper violence a
réussi à faire fléchir l'état on a donné
raison au chantage à la violence et qui
s'aiment
évidemment le désordre récolte la
violence et pourtant si on prend
l'exemple des black blocs qui était
présent dans la manifestation hier et
bien les responsables politiques ont
fait des lois vous avez d'ailleurs été
l'auteur de deux textes sur sur ces
black bloc et on voit que ça ne marche
pas
ce n'est pas efficace si ça peut tout à
fait fonctionner puisque le texte que
nous avions initiée ça permet de
condamner des délits notamment pour ceux
qui se cachent derrière des masques qui
se cache notamment derrière des cagoules
voilà simplement ce que je constate
c'est que quand on a un ministre de
l'intérieur ministre de la justice qui
désavouent leurs troupes qui abandonne
les forces de police ou de gendarmerie
il faut pas s'étonner que les
délinquants s'en sortent finalement et
se sentent renforcés
alors parlons des violences à dijon
qu'on a vu ces derniers jours avec un
affrontement entre la communauté
tchétchène et les habitants du quartier
des grésillés à dijon
est ce qu'il y a eu un laxisme d'état
comme le dit marine le pen avec une
faille les forces de l'ordre pour réagir
à temps assez violente et il ya bien sûr
un sentiment d'impunité
quand certains parlent de violence
policière c'est plus tout simplement
pour déconsidérer la gendarmerie vendée
considérer aussi la police et on voit
bien que désormais la police la
gendarmerie ne peuvent même plus aller
dans certains quartiers c'est une
impunité qu'on a totalement organisée
la france s'est livré désormais au
tribalisme et donc il faut réagir et
quand le chef de l'état en réalité dit
que en tout cas l'elysée dit que ces
gens là les réfugiés qui ont commis des
fautes seraient expulsés c'est fou parce
que pour expulser des réfugiés en france
il faut des condamnations très grave ils
font que par exemple on est atteint la
sûreté de l'état par exemple pour le
terrorisme ou qu'on a écopé d'une peine
ferme de prison de dix années donc il ya
très peu d'exclusion et moi ce que je
propose ce que je vais proposer dans les
jours prochains
c'est une proposition de loi qu'on
modifie la loi pour faire en sorte que
ces gens auxquels la france finalement
donne sa générosité tend la main et qui
sont réfugiés dans de prix lorsqu'ils ne
respectent pas la loi notre loi
républicaine et bien c'est dehors ça
voudrait dire baisser le seuil de
sanctions pour rien sur cd insu elle
serait le seul parent exil écoutez on
les tue 10 mais il n'est pas question
que la république restent désarmés
vis-à-vis de celle de ce qu'elle
accueille généreusement sur son
territoire et qui lui font un pied de
nez et qui ne respectent pas ses lois
sénant ses moeurs vous parliez de
tribalisme dans les quartiers l'ancien
premier ministre manuel valls
aujourd'hui à évoquer et bien une guerre
des races qui remplacerait la lutte des
classes est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse
mais effectivement effectivement en
france malheureusement il y à un racisme
aujourd'hui il y à un racisme un
antiracisme qui veut racisées des
rapports sociaux
il ya une mouvance des colonialistes il
ya une mouvance qui est une mouvance
aussi indigéniste qui voudrait
finalement aboutir à ce que ya une forme
de prise de conscience raciale dans la
société française en opposant les
dominés et les dominants les noirs et
les blancs les jaunes et je ne sais pas
et ça c'est contraire à notre modèle
républicain
on est français parce que on n'est pas
de telle ou telle couleur de peau mais
parce qu'on partage un héritage parce
que il ya un projet en commun
et ça il faut absolument le rappeler
mais justement ses divisions dans la
société française dont il a beaucoup été
question dans cette séance cet après
midi est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle ne
s'explique pas aussi par des inégalités
sociales des inégalités de traitement
entre les citoyens
c'est le communautarisme ce qui explique
en réalité la tribalisation s'est
fracturé là c'est tout simplement qu' il
ya un certain nombre de groupuscules et
notamment l'ultra gauche mais d'autres
mouvances comme je l'expliquais ya
quelques instants qui veulent
communautariser la société française qui
veulent fracturé le modèle républicain
et il faut à tout prix s'opposer très
bien merci